keep the door here
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
do
[Music]
who are you
i'm third chair now dave
hey what's going on
i'm third chair now
[Music]
no you're not
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
i could never make it
[Music]
[Music]
we'll live forever
[Music]
[Music]
dot com
[Music]
is
hmm
wonderful it's very nice to have you
here dave thank you
i'm glad you're here yes that uh to
clear up the gay rumors yes you uh you
don't have to be so
self-conscious you don't need to be so
sad
you're irreplaceable
except for when you are 12 right uh
except for monday yeah we replaced you
except for monday so and it was a pink
slip in my locker it was surprisingly
easy yeah i didn't even know we had
lockers you just bought one together
pink slips pinks you punk ownership
papers
name that movie line you can comment
below right away uh are you are we i'm
sounding a little out of my headphone
for some reason it could just be me
sounding like right it's my it's my own
headphone all right glad to be with you
guys we're gonna be talking about uh
russia and uh uh how uh not only russia
you know is screwing up the ukraine yep
uh taking it over and screwing it up
yeah
well i don't think they're worried about
long lines at the store so much as dying
i don't want to be anti-russian
okay we'll be talking about how uh all
chinese people are racist i have an
anti-russian
[Music]
uh no not all chinese people are racist
no just a significant portion of that
well and just those who do work with the
nba and just those who support the
genocide of the uh the uyghur muslims in
china so there's a lot going on here
internationally uh and you know what we
wanted to break from covet but you know
what also is striking is how much the
united states is becoming like soviet
russia vladimir putin said this oh and i
thought oh come on he's just trying to
you know do his his election meddling
yeah but then i started thinking about
it and i went through and i said he
makes you know what he makes a good case
correct you know even before eminem
detroit had a lot of weakers yes i can
imagine
[Laughter]
not on the outset dave
uh so by the way if we are not here on
youtube if ever it happens uh
we're still streaming monday through
thursday
10 a.m eastern you can watch us on
rumble you can watch us on mug club uh i
don't know why i'm sounding so loud on
my headphones are you really i'm sending
i think it's in your head i think it
could be in my head i've been up since 2
30. you had one of those days when you
cannot fall back asleep you don't sound
loud okay well in my head i sound loud
well that's good everyone else been up
since 230 no what are you talking about
you're gonna make up for it with two
with more caffeine and then it's just
there's a certain point where it makes
you more tired yeah you're going to
crash like right after the show why are
you wearing butterflies i'm not
this ought to be interesting everything
looks like so uh before i move on here
oh jill day how are you i am much better
than you how are you i'm fine you know
we'll just see it get loosey-goosey and
uh you know you guys can keep me in
check that's gonna be funny there you go
some responsibility on your shoulders no
dave
what and of course she's performing uh
february fourth and fifth at the improv
in denver colorado dave landau how are
you ahoy i'm good about you well we've
already gone through do we need to do
the pl let's do away with the
pleasantries no if we're gonna be like
russia let's go full bore and be just
like russia look you beat a man almost
to death a few moments ago i think we
can say ahoy i appreciate you covering
our tracks with almost no yes well
all no employees were armed in the
making of uh well let's just displays
are always harmed
it's an exception to the rule yeah i
don't know why we get so you know we
have full budget for the studio for the
effects the sketches we get really
really uh chintzy we get cheap when it
comes to the grapes well we make them
dig them you know just like i don't know
why we're so frugal with the graves guys
you know what it is they're so hurt when
we have them dig the grave we should
have them dig the grave before we heard
it's true that would make better yeah
they're so worn out i don't know why it
never occurred to me before no i never
thought about it i mean if you think
about it really otherwise what's the
point of forced labor that's true yeah
you got a great we're not taking
advantage we need to be more efficient
with our with our indentured servitude
uh my question to you before we move on
here too is uh
look before we go on to russia and uh in
in china and all the racism that exists
across the globe uh outside of the
united states
filibuster
stephen colbert in his comedy uh wants
us to not only end the filibuster but
end the senate oh okay which we'll talk
about oh good and where because i know a
lot of you folks you know sort of
switched a lot of people who watched you
were you know democrats who then with
donald trump sort of were welcomed into
the fold
i i'm just curious across the
generations you know i want to see a
good sample size people in their 20s
versus people in their 70s it seems like
people have different views of the
filibuster probably because older people
remember when the democrats used the two
longest filibusters ever to stop the
civil rights act wow yeah with an actual
klansman really so they probably look
upon it and like oh i remember that
whereas 20 year olds have no idea who is
the klansmen
uh robert byrd oh right he didn't just
gamble in uh klansmanship he had clan uh
dental in a company car he was a high
right yeah he had a 401k for lynching
isn't it odd they drove a black car
i have no idea you know that is weird i
think he was trying to throw us off the
center okay so before we uh go on to
stephen colbert let's uh start with
china since we're talking about
communists and people uh you know who
could become the next global superpower
hope you and hope you enjoy your tweets
uh propaganda in china is uh uh look uh
i don't they just released something i
haven't watched this yet i wasn't
supposed to they've made some new
propaganda and apparently it's uh
something
everyone here said i should see this
this is real this is real chinese state
propaganda it's a real chinese state
propaganda okay all right that's good to
know
okay now i'm now i feel uncomfortable
we're doing this on the outside of the
show live because you're like we didn't
make this
no one's going to believe that for a
second
it would be more likely that snl made it
okay all right
okay is it [ __ ]
i think that was the point dave
all right let's watch this i i'm tr
doing a trust fall
hold on god because super spy always
prefers to stay low-key ah
is it because emma has asked us to
become more open to stay a secret like
squeeze b and what have the chinese done
well according to this dossier their
national security agency was authorized
to monitor all phone and internet users
in chinese lifetimes that's pretty
outrageous i didn't know china produced
english language films oh wait wait good
grief that's not china we're talking
about that's america excuse me again
and speak american not english that
tribe data trap fish tribe they're all
the same to me the reality is that we do
need money and we have m to thank for
that java
the name is pond
james pond and how's my lovely agent
black window today who's talking still
place is it bosley are you still cross
dressing this is about fire it's called
undercover work my dear black window hey
pond my advice is not to buy yourself a
huawei phone but huawei well that's how
you pronounce it wait how did you know i
was going to get one i don't think there
should be any secrets between you and me
right what you tapped my pharyn again
now he's doing a british accent
best presence for best allies wait why
do stan only have a british accent now
because i've been assigned to spy on the
great united kingdom
okay so first off it probably would have
been better had i watched it before
because i have no idea what just
happened what the hell is that from
it's chinese propaganda but usually
propaganda has a goal how are they
they're trying to convince people of
what that americans spy on their people
i guess i guess but then it's something
about the united kingdom and why is it
there's james pond and then black window
and then bosley who's a charlie's angels
thing
they're just mixing it all together
that's a whole swirl of nonsense it's
just
exquisite where the hell did they get
that from like well they got it from
awesome i don't know my other
catchphrase
[Laughter]
remember because i'm always like squeeze
me and they're in the audience collapse
they're big fans of you in china they
are yeah they have well you have it on
closed circuit tv at the uyghur camps
yes that's true there's a lot of uyghurs
that are big fans
funny man make joke about detroit funny
man is that punishment or uh i like him
yeah this is like chinese water torture
but for uyghur only watch dave landau
special
tape eye opener i love it like hey you
guys get more wreck time today no no no
no no no no no more landau no it's good
i have a lot of james pond jokes
[Laughter]
does anyone know what they're trying are
they trying to convince their citizens
that americans spy americans are worse
than but if that if they're trying to
say that americans spy on their citizens
they just threw huawei under the bus
yeah well wait a minute highway highway
highway i can't i still highway to
shitty content in china well and both
those actors dug their own graves right
after they filmed that i know they
should have done it before they filmed
it i know right exhausting to make
something tired bad he only got down
about six inches
you tapped my phone again
i so tired from doing bad british accent
james palm
make my mouth
soar bad for crying out loud you know
what look china if you're gonna make
state propaganda okay fire fire a salvo
back at the united states one of the
stereotypes that we have of the chinese
people i'm not saying it's correct is
that you can't act
actually feeling better about our
chances against china we'll show we'll
show you we'll show you no no no no
we'll show you who can't act eat your
heart out gene hackman they they just
made that bollywood film we watched
yesterday look good oh yeah well you
know they just sit down and turn on the
tv and they're like what is this and
they just change the channel it's the
same thing engine channel is the same
thing change your channel it's a chinese
man as an indian
just kidding watch more propaganda
us bad we're good we're good we're good
it's peter pan
oh my gosh okay
thank you thank god for tick tock uh now
let's move on to this while we're on the
theme of horrendously unfunny uh stephen
colbert's
gosh
i mean i i it's sad for me because
stephen colbert was really funny i don't
know what you guys thought i liked
comment on comedy central i thought the
character was was perfect i had high
hopes when i found out that he would be
replacing david letterman who i believe
is the best of all time yeah so they
follow the best of all time with this
yeah it's like a reverse ringer yeah
like i remember 10 years ago he did a an
interview for rolling stone and it was
all about how he's moderate when it
comes to politics right you know
well yeah but i mean that i think that
is the true him like this he's just a
walking pfizer ad now well pretty much i
mean like well he are we allowed to say
that i'm sorry no they've actually
purchased his body space oh have they
okay yeah as a matter of fact that was a
contract dispute because modern is
having him wrapped yes that's true they
had his soul but he's the first person
to actually sell his body as well
bundled yep johnson and johnson's like
we'll be over here yeah
we have killed enough three we figured
that we get uh more bang for our buck
more real estate dollar with james
corden yes
you just put them on a post in times
square people are none the wiser no more
tears was a really bad idea for you he's
the best agent ever he's not james
corden is now doing weight watchers
commercials
is he watching it go up
it's like hitting the with a mallet at
the carnival yeah
oh no oh god another job i got more fat
i lost i lost all this weight what'd you
do i don't swallow anymore oh yeah oh my
gosh not on the outside ah
yeah how about giant all right so monday
stephen colbert uh not only ranted about
the film and this is the thing i i do
give a lot of leeway to comedians they
need that space yeah
but when they don't use it for comedy at
all and i'm not just saying this uh
because i disagree with him objectively
this is beyond claptor he advocates it
first for ending the filibuster which
you'll see but then he has elizabeth
warren on and he goes so hard left that
it makes elizabeth warren go into her
dad uh white dad at wedding dance which
is how she always talks like a
marionette here watch
democrats hope to spend the holiday
passing much needed voting rights
legislation to do that they have to
modify the filibuster but that dream
died last night
thank you arizona senator and mrs
hamburgler
kirsten cinema
last week senator cinema took to the
center floor to announce that while she
values voting the filibuster is her
first love while i continue to support
these bills
i will not support separate actions that
worsen the underlying disease remember
when carson used to run two minute clips
from c-span what is the legislative
filibuster other than a tool
that requires new federal policy to be
broadly supported by senators
representing a broader cross-section of
americans reasonable no yeah no
not representing a broader cross-section
of americans yes the 50 senators who are
currently filibustering the voting
rights bill represent 41 million fewer
americans than the senators who support
it
the filibuster is anything other
only joke thus far is hamburglar stop
acting and it wasn't
anything other than an anti-democratic
tool
which is also a pretty good description
of kirsten cinema step aside john
rickles if you can't get rid of the
filibuster oh boy what about
tomahawk jones or this objectively i'm
ready what if
we just get rid of the senate
and i'm 100 serious here the target is
the most
anti-democratic institution
next to the judiciary because the
judiciary is only the way it is because
the senate is the way it is no one would
drop a single tier you've already got
tenure you can go back to your old job
you'll be fine she doesn't even know how
to handle this because it's so fun
possible positive purpose the united
states senate
provides right now watch this i'm kind
of [ __ ] wow
look
ugh
i hear you
first off there's just something so
off-putting i mean it's like the way a
white dad dances at a wedding like
that's her native movements be careful
yeah it's her native movements yeah come
on but she is just the most awkward
human being in that conversation it's
her rain dancing then there's a flood oh
no uh
i just and what purpose does the senate
serve
does this has this has he never seen
schoolhouse rock does he want the
redacted version and then i'll be
sitting in committee and then
i'll just be law because elizabeth i
came from elizabeth warren's husband's
snatch
i get pegged all the time no
i mean look the whole reason is there's
a check and balance right yes you go
through a process and keep in mind this
is we'll talk about this tomorrow when
people say you want to fundamentally
transform america they they accuse the
right of wanting to do this by
a few people you know who were you know
well the most violent insurrection
that's ever taken place had a problem
with the certification of the election
when states actually uh you know
violated their own state constitutions
let's talk about that we'll talk about
who wants to fundamentally transform
america you want to do away with the
filibuster this guy wants to do away
with the senate namely one thing that
conservatives want to fundamentally
transform that would take us away from
the america that you've known and loved
yeah second amendment no first amendment
no property rights no free speech no
we we can go through it a permanent
fencing class no
the left wants to do away with all of it
they want to pack the court they want to
end the so let's just picture that for a
second you wonder what it would take for
us to be australia to be canada to be
the uk it would okay get rid of the
filibuster get rid of the senate which
even elizabeth warren is like
i don't know uh and then pack the court
there are no checks and balances none
whatsoever and by the way what he really
should be saying is we couldn't convince
all of our members of our party to vote
for this legislation or eight other
people in the senate to vote for this
legislation and so now we're pouty faced
and we're trying to take our ball and go
home it's like you're the worst used car
salesman ever and so you just want to
mandate people to buy your old buick
that should be a sign that the
legislation that you're trying to pass
is a bad idea by the way house and
senate house represents the will of the
people because you have to be voted in
every two years we wanted adults in the
senate that weren't going to be aoc
basically and by the way when he says 40
uh 40 something million americans they
also include non-citizens let's just
think about that for a second so pack
the supreme court okay and the
filibuster so you can ram everything
through and by the way let's make sure
that uh the majority can uh obviously be
tyrannical they can uh yeah yeah yeah it
goes from the right of the microphone to
just totalitarianism well it goes to mob
rule and then totalitarianism and by the
way the people who are determining your
elected officials may not even be
citizens of this country so this is the
i think i found the disconnect people
say why can't we find common ground
uh and we used to be able to like if you
look back at a jfk uh if you look back
you know jfk that ended well yeah
they had a lot more income if you look
at jfk and nixon even look at uh even
look at ronald reagan and bill clinton
right they had more in common the issue
here is right now when he says 41
million people he's talking about people
who should you know not be required to
have identification whatsoever in voting
and by the way there has been
legislation of course we just talked
about this in manhattan where you don't
even have to be a citizen the right at
least or certainly people in this room
when we are talking about people who
should be represented in our government
we are talking about american citizens
the left is speaking to everyone but
because that's what that's what they
require as a new voting base for
consistent results otherwise it goes
back and forth and oh we're back to
checks and balances yeah it's the most
idiotic argument i've ever heard the
house gives that extra representation
for people that are states that have
more people and districts that have more
people and i'm done problem solved move
on but they are losing and they don't
like that and 75 of americans support
voter id and that's and but i know you
know there's a cultural disconnect no 73
percent of black americans support
support voter id oh well that's racist
against themselves then why is the
democrat party so racist why why are you
going against the will of your black
constituents now known as the moderate
wing of your party
you mean the wing that started voting
for donald trump in record numbers uh
you know what i want you know what i
want we should start a a whitehouse.org
or whatever the petition whatever it is
change that which one is the thing
change.org for elizabeth warren to spend
20 minutes in any black urban area any
in the country just see how she fares
no i would we have to pick a special
place hey kids would you like to uh have
some of my soul food what the [ __ ] is
this like die hard three where she has
to wear like a placard as well and walk
in yeah i haven't seen your heart oh
come on
you have seen die hard
i have not seen die hard 3. it's a
sandwich board that is very racist is it
it is i seriously haven't seen die hard
all right we'll bring it up on mud club
because i'm sure what was allowed in the
theaters now would not be permissible
but we will have her stand in harlem
with the very same sound okay there we
go yeah
let's see what happens oh okay but i'm
native american yeah exactly i'm a
democrat was here first stop hitting me
with a bottle
i bet we outlawed 40s we can we can't
get big goals but you can still have 40s
that doesn't seem right i haven't seen
an oe 64 handle since my younger days
back when i was i loved liquor
works worked every time something like
that made me feel good so now we'll move
on to china a little bit and then go
into russia i don't usually like
speaking on international issues because
i largely don't care unfortunately uh
and what what do i mean by that is
america's the best country in the world
and uh america is the most significant
player in the world and uh i just don't
care that much
i was raised in canada and all we did
was focus on the united states so now
that i'm in the united states i just
focus on the united states uh that being
said not a big fan of russia not a big
fan of china and if you see what's
happening internationally and you
compare it to what was taking place um
for the four years under donald trump
there is a stark contrast again let's
not talk about mean tweets let's talk
about results so monday golden state
warriors part owner um
chamath let me make sure i have this
right chamath pali paliha pitaya chamath
pali hapati get an american name it's
jamas smith
it's paulie
yeah
okay of course i'm sure none of us got
that right he says this is golden state
warriors he's a part owner he said on uh
this podcast that no one now for those
of you who don't know uyghurs are
chinese muslims and there's an actual
genocide that's been oh i was way off
yeah uh this is what he said on his
podcast about weakers
nobody cares about it
nobody cares about what's happening to
the weakers okay you you bring it up
because you really care and i think what
do you mean
the rest of us don't care what i'm just
telling you very hard you're saying you
personally don't care i'm telling you a
very hard ugly truth okay of all the
things that i care about yes it is below
my line
okay of all the things that i care about
it is below my line so that's one of
those things that even if you feel uh
that evilly you don't say it
i didn't i thought this was like a
parody and somebody was lying to me and
it was click bait or something no i know
i think publicly saying you're for
genocide is a bad thing you wouldn't
think so i mean i'm even just a little
bit nervous like if i'm you know if i go
bird watching and i point i'm like let
me get my hand i don't want to you know
accidentally salute right and this guy's
just like i don't give a rat's ass what
you do to chinese muslims kill them i
don't care yeah i mean how often are you
bird watching
it's a cover you just gotta point peely
michigan like that's the red breasted
sparrow well i'm still aiming for a good
year uh four people who bird watch get
that now let's contrast this
with uh how the warriors head coach uh
steve steve kerr was his name and see i
don't know sports that well but i do
remember this reacted to the shooting of
now keep in mind for those who have
forgotten black guy uh jacob blake who
was violating a restraining order
against his baby mama who he had
sexually assaulted before and she called
the cops so let's compare what that guy
just said about uh uh chinese uyghur
muslims actual genocide actual racism
versus the race baiting that you see
from the golden state warriors coach mr
kerr what i think i've
learned that's most important is really
the definition of racism you know i
think as a white what is a person i
think we all think of racism as an act
we think of some person
uh using a bad uh racial epitaph to
refer to somebody that would be words a
guy in a hood
you know burning across um
racism is really uh a system
um
yeah look at your house jackass heart is
huge
well but i think lots of us think of
racism as you know actions like someone
you know someone actually being racist
but in reality it's something more
nebulous that i can't define but the
good thing is you said system so let's
hold you to system do you mean like a
system that that systematically
sterilizes
muslim chinese citizens
that's what's happening when you look at
the actual genocide that's going on in
china right now and i've known about
this for a while because i went to
guantanamo bay and there was a weaker
prison oh really i remember it and i
thought yeah i thought the term was
funny and that's when i learned about it
in 2009.
and there's also pretty strong evidence
to suggest that china is engaging in
organ harvesting of ethnic minorities in
china but i do want it makes you wonder
why why do you think the nba is hard
why don't they care
[Music]
could it
[Music]
is it possible
oh wait that's right maybe because they
have a 500 million dollar annual
contract with china right now 1.5
billion over the next five years signed
with just one chinese company tencent
well
yeah well that might do it i guess
they're gonna sit there and they're
going to take a knee for a guy who's not
even in their sport
and then they're completely silent at
forced sterilization by the way and i'm
also confused because i thought you guys
loved muslims yeah
i thought that was your favorite i don't
understand the hierarchy anymore i
really don't no there's a line yeah yes
and he cares below he cares
an [ __ ] thermometer right yeah yeah
him making 500 million dollars is above
the line i know that's not just his
money it goes to the rest of the nba
teams it gets distributed but by the way
this guy
in california feels so comfortable and
knows that he will not get called out on
this that he says that on a podcast that
is publicly available to anyone his own
podcast yeah his own podcast he feels so
comfortable in his bubble in the
people's republic of california that he
feels does he realize that the internet
is a global phenomenon
okay why don't we try and switch this a
little bit i don't want this taken out
of context so i'm going to be very
careful and don't all right so let's
just say you know this is like an nba
owner like this guy saying not me this
guy's saying yeah the the things that
are going on in rwanda are just
he would say below his line yeah right
yes in africa you remember when that
acts of genocide were happening and
genocide was happening you know hotel
rwanda that great movie yeah there was
something about that yeah fantastic
hotels
so you could see it right yes that would
be below his line if you want to care
about do you think the world might go
well wait a minute what how can you
possibly say well i think you get an
angry call from don cheadle alec baldwin
and glenn gary glenn ross wouldn't say
that behind closed doors right i mean
that is a commitment get a side date you
know what a pull your dick out move that
was to just say like i can say whatever
i want yeah i don't care about jenna
organ harvesting i'll take two livers
what's my name
f.u that's my name i do care about
wiggers because i'm not a monster yes i
have a fridge filled with kidneys just
in case mine don't work qurans are for
closers you see that much
that watch is not worth as much as a
weaker life because all life is precious
[Laughter]
so now well here it would be one thing
if they were supporting let's say a
government that was progressive right
the chinese communist government
i call it ccp for short but you can take
it
uh so the communist chinese government
the chai comes you can use that term
there we go
i coined it um
but let's look at the track record of of
uh not only the communist chinese
government but a lot of people don't
understand this because you think that
all racism is just white versus black in
the united states um
you know what i don't know how to get to
this let's just say this is pretty
racist and it happened in china uh
recently and uh it's not just the one
guy saying it it's the whole group of
people around this guy who support him
saying it
uh against a basketball team yes against
the basketball team which is also um i
mean the irony here with the nba like i
don't know how they're i don't know how
this works and you'll understand what
i'm saying once you watch this clip
[Music]
of
oh
china
what did i just see
what
well stephen if i may uh the chinese
phrase
yeah
is similar that'll be used against me is
similar to uh um or well that's what oh
i'm pretty sure they're trying to say in
their culture it's a nice he's trying to
think of a nice compliment for the
sportsman coming out of the bus so it's
like if you play it again like i want to
show you guys uh in context yeah uh you
know
that it's a mix of okay it's a diet it's
a dialect thing it's okay it's simply a
dialect and you'll you'll see from the
clips
this is culturally specific so based on
your native language like in china the
common word is that that that that so in
china it might be nega [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
[ __ ] [ __ ]
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
[ __ ] this is culturally specific
what's up my [ __ ]
see classic mix up yeah that just
happens that's the cloud well that would
explain borrow a pencil that would
explain kenosha's infamous uh joseph
rosenchan yes that's right
[Laughter]
how's he doing
[Laughter]
deep grave yeah very good it's been uh
um now here's the thing
[Laughter]
i mean you're going to give a pass to
everyone but
i hadn't seen the last part of that i
don't know what do i need what do i need
do i
we've talked about hood past do i need a
pedophile pass
do i need a racist chinese pest by the
way we're going to have on mug club
stuff that we can never talk about on
youtube uh choi sauce uh who's korean
here he'll be sitting with us on mug
club for people who are not your members
describing some of
giving us more context into the
inter-asian racism that exists there's
nationalism there's actual racial
superiority a lot of people don't
understand because they're used to the
united states yeah and
even though to most americans the
average for example let's say north
korea and south korea would look more
similar than uh me and uh chimath
chamath smith the different our
differences are actually less
significant culturally and the
difference is as far as the animosity
towards people who they view as another
race for example if you look at the
japanese and you look at the chinese uh
in the world war ii era and you look at
what happened in these internment camps
it's unbelievable hatred based on this
idea of racial superiority and it's
baked into a lot of asian cultures you
need to understand this and then you can
have a better contextualizing
of what's going on with uyghurs it's not
an isolated incident right and racism
doesn't exist outside of the united
states i just want to make sure that's
clear from what we're saying here it's
only the united states that racist and
it's only white people against black
people and asians yes no be clear now
chinese are pretty they're there can
often be racist towards a lot of other
asians let's i think we have a clip here
from 2012 is this the anti-japanese
protest over the senkaku islands let's
roll the clip probably
at first glance this might look like an
anti-police protest
but these chinese demonstrators in
shenzhen aren't attacking the vehicle
because it's a police car but because it
was made in japan
there were similar protests in beijing
hong kong and other cities targeting
japanese businesses as well as property
oh well that makes it right yeah that
would be the equivalent to uh if here in
the united states the people who were
you know um destroying cop cars were
actually just a bunch of rednecks like
you're driving a camera you should've
bought american right you imagine my
camry was behind you you're like you
know i'm not stopping yes
it's a corolla
yeah
don't wait up yeah have a good one in
fairness the car shouldn't have been
dressed that way the car show that is
true that's what happens car was making
eyes
call that a race and to be fair also
japanese uh they had raped and a lot of
chinese people and use them as uh human
guinea pigs oh wow oh so you know look
they have reason to be upset
about 20 million people died there was
an eyewitness lee kihan who said there
are so many bodies in the street victims
of group uh group rape and murder they
were all stripped naked their breasts
cut off leaving a terrible dark brown
hole some of them were bayoneted in the
abdomen with their intestines spilling
out alongside them some had a roll of
paper a piece of wood stuffed in anyway
the point we'll have a bunch of rev i
don't even feel like talking about this
one
gender reassignment surgery effectively
but the problem is it's not it's not
voluntary right you don't want to have
that unless you're into it no they're
not an american six-year-old i see they
don't have the ability to consent if
they were only yeah so uh read also up
on unit says 731. i have it written here
but i don't want to i don't want to talk
about it's terrible it's so awful it's
the kind of thing if you don't believe
in evil look at what the japanese did to
the chinese in these internment camps i
do want my magazine back after
well that's nice well you read it for
the articles it is what i really do yeah
and the foldins
the foldins are pretty good
there's miss 1937. that's james pond no
tits
that was the plan so this boner
take that off the soundboard immediately
replace it with something worse well i
guess we can move on from china to worse
let's talk about russia and the ukraine
right what sorry so uh secretary of
state anthony blinken is in kiev
today uh hoping to calm some tensions of
course between the ukraine and russia
now this is because we were on air
yesterday and now we're sort of seeing
it develop a little bit more russia
began sending troops westward into
belarus
here's a clip to give you some context
russia and belarus will rehearse
repelling an external attack when they
hold joint military drills in belarus
next month both sides said on tuesday
it comes at a time of acute tensions
with the west over neighbouring ukraine
russian military forces and hardware
began arriving in ex-soviet surprises
with nato members poland and lithuania
the west has voiced fears of a possible
invasion of ukraine by tens of thousands
of russian troops gathered near its
border well here's the thing let's you
don't let your heart be troubled because
the ukraine is getting military support
from their greatest ally
canada ah what do they send mounties yep
yep don't worry you'll get those piston
planes with shotguns any day now
don't shoot the propeller is brendan
fraser on a horse
i'll save you ukraine ukraine's in
trouble we must save her
i'm dead to do right are they gonna keep
from having forest fires or something
come on
no no just this outfit and this horse
yes he's arabian look at his feet you're
eating my horse
[Laughter]
one equine enthusiast is appreciative of
that uh by the way speaking of rush i
don't know how to tie this in hit the
notification bell if you're watching
here on youtube because the subscription
box doesn't mean anything and that'll
let you know when you have but really
it's monday through thursday at 10 a.m
eastern with the exception of sometimes
when we shoot you know live on location
or we do a super video or we're putting
together a package um let's move on here
with russia
and uh more so the soviet union because
look if you understand what russia's
looking to do they're looking to
consolidate power and if you understand
why that is dangerous well here's the
thing if you don't understand why it's
dangerous i don't i'm confused because
didn't the fate of our republic hang in
the balance because uh in 2016 some
russian operatives bought like three
thousand dollars worth of facebook ads
no no that's actually not true anymore
okay yeah oh no no i mean now i'm just
confused i don't understand the rulebook
it was being prostitutes that's actually
the problem yeah you're talking about it
not a problem so vladimir putin uh said
and i watched it sounds like this guy's
just trying to push more propaganda not
as effective as james pond
no no and well that's just correct not
all propaganda is created equal huge
budget slick sandwich
more than one cigar how funny would it
be if they filmed it at the youtube
studios
well i think people were interesting if
they didn't no no no no no we'll we'll
we will film in marina del rey
youtube studio they're very welcome yes
half draw in fridge just for chinese
propagandists
[Laughter]
hello susan wojcicki be sure fridge have
my overnight alts
so vladimir putin said that the u.s is
becoming a soviet union here's him
saying it and then i actually don't
think he's wrong
so for people who are listening on audio
and again if you're not a member of mud
club or you're not a rebel you can
listen to us on uh
apple on spotify android uh he's talking
about the why the soviet union didn't
work as an empire yeah and then he's
comparing it to the united states
there's something in there that i don't
fully understand we're saying and they
convinced some people with battleships
and give these other person necklace
it's like
they give the necklace you show your
titties and this is art and this is how
the decadence of the west
is the street with bourbon i don't
understand but i show bids she chose
tits this is not social contract which
makes sense in russia but i am
conflicted because i like tits
she says no four times and then maybe
yes yes yes and by the way
maybe in russia is irrelevant yes
because no can mean yes
i look for women with very sexy frown
yes
there is you'll know what gets me hard
post is resting [ __ ] face it's rbf very
close to kgb beautiful woman three hairs
on face mall yes beautiful
i like lady who use epilator on upper
lip
our prison system is filled with men
and many men want to get in there
because of the unfortunate appearance of
our women yes that's true also they have
better food yes
we only get bread outside on the inside
you get bread and protein in the shower
in prison that's right you get all kind
you get three square meals a day you
have to get tattoo of grim reaper with
baby on baby but it's price to pay
is true
now uh one of the first things going
into uh uh
sort of the soviet union for people who
understand the history the bolsheviks
uh one of the first things they did when
they seized power and well let's compare
this to the united states today the
radical left okay and let's be clear if
you're talking about lenin stalin right
you're talking about marxism you are
talking about russia's soviet union yeah
okay you can't i know some people say
well you know what they didn't try solar
system correctly okay fine i get it
you'll make it work with fat pride
activists today who don't actually work
got it now let's use the actual examples
of socialism of of uh leninism of
communism how it's been implemented and
how that evolved into the soviet union
and compare it to the far left today in
the united states far left russia far
left today okay well the first things
that bolsheviks did uh when they seized
power was they tried to censor the press
that's one of the first things they did
that's what you have to do right away is
control the information that goes out
well do we have any examples that are
comparable to that in the united states
today i hope not
don't play we do we do yeah we do we
have facebook we have google uh we have
twitter they all blocked what do they
block they blocked the hunter lap hunter
biden laptop story which would have
changed the election you don't even need
to worry about mail-in voting according
to the american people their vote would
have been changed had they seen the
hunter by the laptop story um you have
covid treatments you have the vaccine
efficacy you're not allowed to speak out
on these i don't get fact checked we've
been suspended for that uh they
de-platformed a sitting president
in donald trump but not the ayatollah
khamenei not the ayatollah committee yep
calling for the destruction of the jews
he wouldn't you know you know what hell
not even that guy who's the golden state
warriors co-owner saying ah you can kill
all the muslims
i just it doesn't meet the bar just
think about that for a second fall
enough
you get rid of donald trump and that guy
stays yeah we don't even need to get to
hezbollah just him
just ban the golden state warriors how
about that
let's just can we send them all to that
crowd that was obviously chanting in
their native tongue that that that they
were attending
i like black people i'm i'm i'm yeah we
totally misunderstood of course also in
the chinese dialect [ __ ] you means i
love the color map no no no far cute
like the faux [ __ ] i want soup yeah
that's exactly i want soup from colored
man that's well i don't know about the
other part um
i want black man soup now we have no
okay there we go yeah yeah yeah that's
better we're getting there so let's uh
stalin while we go through uh kind of
the media and also control the narrative
what did they do they purged uh
not only media but removed disgraced
figures from photographs right they
tried to erase a portion of history
right they just randomly chose who those
disgraced figures
right uh and do we have anything
comparable to that in the united states
uh unfortunately well i don't think
anybody's removed statues george
washington teddy roosevelt thomas
jefferson and abraham lincoln and again
you would think like okay george
washington they were slaves and okay
abraham lincoln
remember he is famous for having a
hangover though and saying i freed the
what yes yeah he also had a crazy wife
he had a bender okay his crazy headache
ridden wife what a pain in the ass i
know i think it was because he gave her
syphilis yeah well you know what and he
was like i don't don't tell
weirdo i don't know how this is
screaming because her brain itches sally
field [ __ ]
saw thank god you arrived go ahead kelly
field played it really well yeah she did
yeah she didn't even know the cameras
were rolling no they were like just be
yourself
[Laughter]
so we have that we have those statues
that are removed and i joked about this
i think in 2016 back when we were in my
den in michigan i said well look i
understand people are but where does
this end are we going to be removing the
statues of abraham lincoln because some
of the things that he said
would still be considered problematic
what about martin luther king jr just
the other day i'm having to use his own
words and i'm going i can't say the
words that he uses to describe black
people i don't think he had any disdain
for black people
by the way he referred to them as um um
um that was the problem yeah my mom um
so soviet uh propaganda let's go through
this uh 1985 cia video about uh soviet
propaganda um sort of i think we have
these is this next clip side by side or
no
uh no okay so then i'll show you the
next clip uh a striking similarity i've
noticed between the soviet
well we're getting so we've changed
history we've changed the media
so we've controlled we've now
effectively gotten rid of portions of
history yeah and we've made sure that we
can control the media this is what the
soviets did right they understood this
was important to shape the now so the
now right now the vast majority of
americans get the information from where
three companies
three companies right you're talking
about google alphabet which is uh google
and youtube facebook
instagram is one company and uh then you
add twitter kind of although twitter is
a distant third and you could add apple
and amazon to the mix so let's say five
companies to be generous although really
it's three ninety percent of information
that travels they've gotten rid of a
sitting president and they decided to
ban some stories that actually affected
the outcome of the election okay so now
you are able to shape the now okay well
the now that you're living in people who
are watching right now you at home the
economy sucks you know it i know it uh
but of course the media
wants to act as though you don't know it
and this is where the similarity becomes
uh becomes very apparent in soviet
russia they decided rid of history
control of media now let's shape the now
even though the entire world knew their
economy was awful uh they made sure that
the media told a different story
the soviet media go to great lengths to
portray the leadership as thoroughly
committed to the welfare of the common
man
shortcomings in the supply of consumer
goods are attributed to individual cases
of managerial inefficiency and
corruption like on the part of lower
level functionaries
the leadership provides excuses and
scapegoats for its economic problems in
an effort to vaccinate criticism from
higher officials and the communist
system not scapegoat that was sheep one
time
not goat it's beautiful beautiful sheep
it was it was beautiful sheep we don't
this goat is just a rumor now this is
very similar to uh let's think about
today's economy um with elizabeth warren
pete buttgig uh they were blaming kroger
they were also trying to claim that the
inflation that you're seeing that harms
all americans big kroger is good uh part
of what's happening isn't just the
supply side it's the demand side demand
is off the charts retail sales are
through the roof and if you think about
those images of uh ships for example
waiting at anchor on the west coast you
know every one of those ships uh is full
of record amounts of goods that
americans are buying it's a great job
this guy does have six with billy goats
yes
think of the example right now for
example with grocery stores remember how
many grocery stores there used to be and
now what you've got is a handful of
giant chains and then what happens uh
kroger uh makes money they want to put
you all back in kroger a quarter of 2021
were almost 900 million dollars that was
more than three times what their profits
were in the same time period in 2019.
now
if they are able to expand profits not
expand prices expand profits
that's because they have a lot of market
dominance here yes take it from little
boy and mushroom cut and man who have
sex with billy goat
sorry billy goat have sex with him well
yes it's power bottom yes macaulay
culkin drawing from kids yes movie i
love it
i love when your senator warren go ah
yes pagemaster tell you not to go to big
kroger yes and she's also the good [ __ ]
yes i love how she just she totally
discredited her army she's like well
they didn't raise their prices they just
got more efficient and made more money
right well that's a problem
not as much of a problem as the senate
or filibuster existing well that's
undemocratic we're selling more products
at the same price you son of a [ __ ]
that is profiteering if i've ever seen
it oh the opposite of price gouging no
it's you're providing more price
stability ing yes we need giant bread
lines
[Laughter]
these are not on bread lines these are
lined for bakery yes because it's
opening day sales yeah 692
so much demand you see now here's some
soviet propaganda that mirrors that
exactly uh
from new york times sorry this is new
york times reporter walter durrante that
wrote
russians hungry but not starving oh good
deaths from disease due to malnutrition
high yet the soviet is entrenched this
is the new york times you know what
maybe mccarthy was right
maybe he had a point
entire country i'm hungry look you're
hungry you're not starving
yeah
have you ever hear of intermittent
fasting it's great way to raise growth
hormones speed up metabolism how you do
is uh you eat nothing for 19 days yes i
walk through now drinking a cup of
coffee and i look around and see boys
with flies on face yup that's all i do
but i don't even notice them because i
had my coffee with coconut oil got to
get your mct's i'm bulletproof
[Music]
yeah they're hungry hungry but not
starving
new york time just to make sure i have
this right new york times reporter
walter durrante wrote this in the united
states this is a united states citizen
writing this incredible [ __ ] and by
the way in exchange for the propaganda i
don't know if you know this the soviet
union or moscow they rewarded durante
with uh a huge uh apartment a car and a
mistress ah
and all the sandwiches russians could
eat yes
well to be fair his mistress was lizzo
right yeah
you thought it was going to be billy
gold no it's just gross i know where all
the bread went there's only two ways out
of this place in her or in a body bag
your choice
more room in her i'd choose her if i
were you by the way uh for whenever she
is no longer around we need very very
deep grave if she is just very deep if
she goes on top your pelvis will break
you will die instantly yes and instead
of recovering we will just use tarp to
save time shatter the anus
now let's compare this to the united
states that was the u.s
pool will be a casket yes
[Laughter]
like chernobyl dumb concrete all over
yes that's it and we'll put flowers in
it make it a nice little you know to
blink like huffle we cannot hide this no
we can
the united states cnn what they actually
wrote here about today's economy uh why
inflation can actually be good for
everyday americans and bad for rich
people yeah i'm sure i'm sure that's
really hitting uh bezos where it hurts
oh yeah oh geez that's a rounding error
on my daily interest he's like it's fine
half my products are laying on the train
tracks in los angeles and i'm still a
billionaire i don't think susan wojcicki
could tell you what what uh the gas
price per gallon has been in the last 10
years
no i'll tell you what the you know the
more well-off i became and i'm certainly
not rich to well not rich but uh i
consider myself uh very fortunate uh i
become less concerned with gas in other
words it makes it easier for me to drive
a larger car because i want something
safer for my kids yeah it's it's less of
uh something that needs to be taken into
account it's less of a factor yeah daily
food and uh necessities for people who
don't have a lot of money when those
prices go up they don't really care it's
actually good for them right yeah and it
helps them listen they're hungry but
they're not starving right okay
yes that's a good thing price of gas
will go up 40 percent will even playing
field with jeff bezos now you have
fighting champs bicycles it's better for
education you know like not education
but it's better for them to get you know
the exercise also ride bicycle to work
yes because it's better for environment
uh and that's why not because we have no
vehicles yes stop global warming or some
[ __ ] yes exactly yes not like the
shortage of uh well take your pick
everything so cnn wrote this uh sorry
that was seen in new york times also
wrote the economy is good so why do we
feel terrible about it
time wrote is this is this journalistic
gaslighting i mean
yes
i mean the term is thrown around so
flippantly now does this not apply right
here the the new york times like no
actually everything's great so why do
you feel maybe the problem is you how's
the economy great we're printing all the
money we want yeah exactly endless yeah
have you ever played monopoly have you
seen the stock market we're propping up
it's doing great it's doing
fantastically well
blackrock just made another uh 19
trillion dollars and they're being too
big to fail so they'll get your tax
dollars i mean what more do you want
from me
is doing awesome i mean they're unreal
they own the world grover have you wait
hold on a second you may think the
economy is going poorly uh mr
middle-class american but uh have you
seen pfizer stock
that's true gone up if anybody invested
before the pandemic you're a rich man
someone looking to uh stephen colbert
for insider trading tips oh well i'm
sure one of the dancing syringes yeah
we're like hey guess what
stock prices are going to soar
i just gave him and it's not because of
this sketch
no so time wrote the secret history of
the shadow campaign that saved the 2020
election let's go on to this too soviet
union united states i think we've made
that case pretty convincingly and again
i'll reference available at
lighterwithcrowder.com you get rid of
the past
statues history founding principles of
this country all right then you control
the media then you gaslight the citizens
you just tell them that what they're
experiencing is not real and there are
other things that need there are other
uh
important factors that need to be
incorporated here uh another one that's
very important with the soviet union or
it was important and it's important with
today's left um you've got to get rid of
religion you've got to get rid of
foundational principles even if you're
let's say you're not a christian let's
say you're an atheist you understand the
tradition at least and why it matters
certainly to this country hopefully you
understand the cultural significance i
see a lot of people now who sort of have
come around on that yeah uh you know the
people who used to use flying spaghetti
monster in this analogy yeah because you
know i always loved that one i watched
that youtube video too well the one with
the fish walking on the back of the cars
i loved it yeah i know and then and then
right next to co-exist it's like but the
one before that is you being an [ __ ]
yeah that's that's like pac-man c's
eating all the rest of the letters guys
so the soviets used propaganda to uh
effectively erase um religion uh this is
something i think a lot of you know it
was a distinctly atheistic uh worldview
people say religion is the cause of all
wars and deaths i don't know a
few hundred million
and now
russia's like holding my beer yeah
yeah it was rough as well still uh i
don't even know i don't even know if it
shows up as a blip compared to what you
had in maui's china what you had with uh
stalin for crying out loud and close and
the point is people fight for a litany
of reasons
that being said there are certain values
that didn't exist until
let's be specific
modern christendom
like mercy like generosity to people who
aren't members of your own faith do you
know how i know that's true hey
how many outsiders did soviet russia
help hey wait a second how many islamic
charities exist today
to help non-muslims
you name any it's an exclusively now you
may say well that was because of
colonization that would be because of
the missionary work fine at the very
least they're still helping people going
across the globe to help people where
they stand nothing to gain well they
stand to gain converting them
and
they can say no and keep the well that
was dug to give them water there's no
muhammad's purse right no there is no
muhammad's purse it just doesn't exist
it's salvationist you guys know of
so remember when you guys used to pray
to uh you know i remember this guy who
was pretty popular for jesus christ
yeah
yes not anymore bill cosby said that was
his brother's name yeah well you know
what uh i can't check him was gd
now and evermore
we ask it in the name of the
monotheistic god brahma
and god known by many names by many
different faiths you are gay
a man
and a woman
and an idiot
somebody help i love this one
she couldn't get up oh thank you george
floyd fighting your life for justice
he did yes we hope we hope you're up
there with all the speed balls you can
snort
oh you chuck gerald
the father and the son and the cup of
soup yes
all the fentanyl you could ever want
which that's like a grain of rice is
probably all you're gonna need
i feel like that's what did it in the
first place but hey we're crying out
loud praying to george floyd yeah
i mean george floyd woke up i think i
must sacrifice myself yeah this is
that's not what happened thank you
george floyd
and by the way our men is not it's not a
gender it's it's our woman it's weird
and the monotheistic god the one with
all the hands and heads that one's my
favorite yeah the elephant with the uh
you know the one with all the elephants
all these arms yeah that one the really
vengeful god that kills or converts
everyone else we all know who that one
is he doesn't like amen yeah uh well
it's a woman when he's anyone seen my
desmond two two he does i need to kneel
i like when he does double dutch walking
into the church i really wish we had the
footage where nancy pelosi right after
kneeling could not get up and had to
have help she's like
yeah well she had just invested inside
her trading with life alert
yeah she flipped your jacket around like
will smith and the fresh prince of
bel-air yeah that's the life alert
commercial i would love to see nancy
pelosi but not just where she's on the
floor like in the post more i want to
see the fall
let me show her tumbling down the stairs
so i mean then i will purchase life
alerts for all family members i want to
see a dark room and a hamper on her yes
yes just the bottom of the steps
her developing pictures in a dark room
she hasn't done any manual labor or
anything around the house ever no no joe
biden that's another thing joe biden
fake talks tough that's a man who has
pushed pencils his entire life oh he got
some hair plugs and convinced himself
that he's a tough guy exactly yeah
because he beat somebody with a chain at
a pool supposedly in the 1930s yeah well
and the guy wasn't even
the guy didn't even see it coming not a
joke i'm a random guy he just walks like
hey what did i tell you because like was
that guy talking to me did he say he
kept saying what i tell you did he say
anything
kids used to push my leg hair down
loved it
so let's also look at some of the
policies between the soviet union and
the united states uh the soviets
instituted a national system
of preschool facilities now lenin called
these facilities the sprouts of
communism he claimed that they would
liberate the woman in reality diminish
and eliminate her inequality to a man
through enhancing her role in his social
production and social life because if
lenin is known for anything it's
improving social lives of the ladies
he loves the ladies by dating them and
the ladies love him and i love him i
mean at gunpoint the weird sex sticks i
mean very very afraid
how did that women's lib work out for
you guys well that's not what we call it
here no no oh so hitler we don't call it
women's lib so much is the shooting
squad it was called hitler youth that
was also bad
you know i like the youth part
the heatler not so much not so much it's
no need to throw baby out with bath
water no but we will throw out the baby
if you don't do what we say well we
throw out baby because there's only so
much food it's one child what we can't
be going around with having babies
you've seen lizzo she eats lots
she's mainly what protects your food
well she did eat lots
thank you lizzo you will be remembered
big life big statue in your honor so uh
a major component too if biden's build
back better was what universal pre-k and
subsidized child care which i know you
would say sounds good because free stuff
yeah always sounds good but think about
that for a second that would increase
the state influence from not only grade
school high school and then if you
forgive all student uh student loans
university i mean you're just talking
about government
government indoctrination for over a
decade of someone's life now this would
go all the way to three years old yeah
so three to 22 essentially you would
have government influence right on your
life i'm not good at math but that
sounds like about 18 years i don't
understand look you guys can con
do you notice this disconnect that takes
place this is something like when people
talk about sort of common ground and
you notice how people used to on the
left typically sort of you know the
patchouli wearing hippies they used to
talk about big money right they would
[ __ ] about big pharma well that's gone
now because they're doing ads for big
pharma they would talk about a conflict
of interest right citizens united well
hold on a second why does that only
apply
when let's say some owner of a business
is giving to a pac to lobby a politician
but you don't see a conflict of interest
when that politician is funding these
institutions themselves do you really
think that government doesn't have a
conflict of interest when they are in
charge of your children for eight nine
hours a day from three years old to 22
do you think that government is going to
be able to objectively teach that child
about the risks of the corruption of
government where did where did your
conflict of interest sniffer go i just
is it is is it me all of a sudden we
understand because i don't it's not
required for me
to cease my understanding of human
nature to maintain my worldview in other
words i fully believe that people who
run businesses will become corrupt i
fully believe that power and wealth can
corrupt that's why i don't think that
chase bank or bank of america should be
too big to fail right that's why i don't
want subsidies i fully understand that
and i fully believe that that applies to
people who have unfettered power in
government who've often never worked a
day in the private sector in their lives
only one side says oh my gosh well you
know you know people who are rich uh and
kroger those people are corrupt you know
people who are rich in the technology
those people are corrupt you know people
who are rich in the moment those people
are corrupt but the people who uh you
know have made millions of dollars have
increased their net worth 4 000 percent
as a representatives their hearts pure
and true it has to apply across the
board yeah you know one other thing you
do and we just mentioned it i'll just
wedge this in here you change the rules
to pass legislation you change the
fundamental rules by getting rid of the
filibuster trying to get rid of the
senate and then you pack judiciary so
that they can rule in your favor yeah
like those guys would be like oh man
like you're following the playbook step
by step yeah
judiciary pack you yeah
patrick duffy yes
now the judge step by step day by day
throw you down them
[Laughter]
all right fredo
hey don't call it i don't know why
that's
that's it
that's their only adaptation to the
patrick duffy's sitcom intro song is
throw you dumb throw you down
step by step you will regret what you've
said
then melissa joan hart makes her cameo
what
step i stepped in boom back is there
anyone more annoying than melissa jones
for crying out loud you explained
nothing in your whole series
so leninist russia what else did they do
well they try to destroy sexual norms
and gender differences this means things
like easy access to abortion uh things
like gay marriage um let's compare that
to united states well i'll just repeat
exactly what i just said abortion gay
marriage okay i think what i'm talking
about here it's like look you guys can
be for these things
but you have to acknowledge at a certain
point the similarities across
the board something else that's pretty
important when you need to create an
empire when you need a state dependent
people is you have to what just like we
just talked about erasing historical
figures
why do you do that because these people
need to be othered they're bad they're
historical figures that should not be
remembered they were corrupt you also
have to do that in the now by othering
political enemies of course you know the
soviets did this the enemies of the
state they were diagnosed with a new
mental illness
uh called sluggish schizophrenia
[Laughter]
yeah they're completely insane seeing
people yeah so much so that they were
kind of lazy about it you can't really
yeah
i mean
it was it was defined by this is
actually this is from we have the source
up here right references available uh
cambridge uh anti-soviet thinking
the illusions of reformism and
overvaluing
[Laughter]
this freedom telltale signs of sluggish
schizophrenia ask your doctor about
gulag
see schoolag is right for you
do you have hopes of freedom peculiar
pure serbia do you believe that life
matters
yes
actually every answer is gulag side
effects might include
gulag yes
and death by lizzo yes do you have
sluggish schizophrenia yes no sluggish
schizophrenia i will read this again
because you probably think i am joking
but you know it's true because of
legitimate accent
and this soviet thinking delusions of
reformism overvaluing freedom in
moderate to severe plaques arrest
not mild yes is from asbestos
so what do we have here in the united
states anything similar well what do we
have we have opponents of the state and
let's be clear about it right now when
facebook youtube twitter instagram all
of these other institutions who have
decided they are going to uh effectively
be symbiotic with the state for example
they're fact checking who who's
determining what what which facts are
permissible the state yeah let's be
really clear this is also the problem
with crony capitalism when people again
talk about the problem with capitalism
okay why all of a sudden do you think
it's inherently altruistic when it's the
biggest tech companies that have ever
existed and they're getting their
marching orders from the state do you
see the problem all i'm asking is that
you recognize the problem consistently
so what have they been labeled by both
the state and big tech
violent domestic terrorists that's one
of the terms that was of course used uh
the unvaccinated is now a catch-all
umbrella conspiracy theorists nazis
don't take my word for it
the unvaccinated overcrowd are hospitals
over running emergency rooms and
intensive care units
the unvaccinated patients are
are leaving no room for someone with a
heart attack or in need of a cancer
operation and so much more because they
can't get into the icu they can't get
into the operating rooms
the unvaccinated also put our economy at
risk the top domestic violent extremist
threat comes from racially or ethnically
motivated violent extremists
specifically those who advocated for the
superiority of the white race
additionally we're increasing the
availability of new medicines
recommended by real doctors not
conspiracy conspiracy theorists these
white supremacists
nazi sympathizers
carrying nazi [ __ ] flags
it's just classic what do you think
putin does when he watches that clip
yeah oh i'm so scared oh yes no i'm so
glad you warned me about nazi [ __ ] and
juicy how many times do i have to say
checkmate before i win games
this is crazy i mean for crying out loud
you put checker pieces on board did you
hear what he said about this it's not
wanting to be vexed oh he lied directly
to them and they're all like yes he's
great right to their face and then he
then he started complaining about
juicing to throw them off this sense yes
we all know american problem with
juicing you sluggish schizophrenic he's
really sluggishly schizophrenic that's
for real we made it up but you really
have
this man with papaya face
constantly one i hope another one's
small oh must have eaten too much
spinach being spoon-fed by the jewels in
me right oh dumbass what the stupid [ __ ]
sorry
now finally let me read you a quote
actually too we even have this from
barack obama that he gave in 2013 um
something along these lines of no no no
no not do not be slaves to religion to
marriage or to children break those old
ties the state is your home your world
is your country no wait hold on a second
that's not um that's yeah that's not
obama it's the soviet revolutionary um
alexandra uh colin ty but you know what
it's easy for me to get it confused
because i think obama said something
similar
people have been beaten down so long
and they feel so betrayed by government
it's not surprising then that they
get better and they cling to guns or
religion or
uh antipathy towards people who aren't
like that but
and
a way to explain
their frustrations probably a closet
homosexual who did a lot of cocaine
was that a camcorder from the 90s jesus
well
i see the irony in him express like
saying you know not people who you know
they cling to their bibles and their
guns and show anticipated people who are
different
like people who cling to their bibles
and guns like like i just i just yeah
it's just do you not understand it's
like now you know for example
you have some you'll have you have some
dumb son of a [ __ ]
who are not nice
the people who disagree
you want to go to bed you don't want to
curse these people these people these
these people who whose mom i just got
off
are getting upset
about the things we say
[Laughter]
don't get all we weed up
vote for me by the way for people who
are watching like who are 20 something
that was a thing that barack obama did
everyone talked about how charming he
was and charismatic he made up words he
said my mom used to say don't get all
wearied up no every everyone looked it's
never been a thing like what yeah well
you know what that's what mom said no no
no that's not what your mom said that's
what my dad said you never met him
oh no he didn't meet him when he was
young
he grew up without his father but it was
the stereotype thing maybe she was just
talking about the bulge in her
daughter-in-law's pants
oh
lord well no she was she was be i don't
know she would say no don't don't get
all michelle up
you don't like it it only gets big when
she dances
what what do you think i said somebody
or somebody else dances yeah that's all
it is depending on who's doing the
dancing it's not it's not what you think
it is and i'm over in the corner
clinging to my guns she has both parts
and bible
she can still give birth praying to god
babies come out under the balls so look
let me let me leave you this uh question
um was putin right
was putin right when he was talking
about uh the united states trying or at
least emulating to some fashion the
previous soviet union you guys can
comment below it's one of the best
things you can do obviously for the
youtube algorithm uh it'll piss them off
something awful yeah you can also smash
that like button to uh see what uh they
think about it hint they're not going to
like it no
no no no i promise you one thing you
smash that youtube like button
9. susan what is going to get all wee
weed up
all the way home wee-wee
that's what now this this this little
michelle went to the marketplace
big kroger and said i saw michelle had
not
i have a wee-wee
now this little lizzo had roast beef
and and not not not now now now now
this little michelle had not
oh
to be fair she had the whole cow i hope
they threw out those flowers
i don't think they could throw out the
flowers i think they just shriveled up
like an e.t on their own yeah you don't
put those in a voss though like you want
to smell them no what
so
here's here's i know where some people
will say we're just complaining uh here
are the solutions how do you fight this
off how do you make sure or at least as
a nation there's a pretty clear actual
there's a pretty clear path to avoiding
this kind of
totalitarianism to avoiding this kind of
it's always so funny because if you
search this google's going to tell you
the totalitarianism that
authoritarianism that this is
exclusively a right-wing phenomenon i
mean i don't know how you you don't
acknowledge stalin or mao as
totalitarian and how you don't
acknowledge them as far left
it does start locally it does start in
your household it does start with your
family what do you do okay first thing
is you get out of cities big cities
we're seeing people do that that's
important they want to herd you into
cities they want you on mass transit
the more people you put in to one
area to a smaller area the more rules
you can create in the name of security
and you can find a willing people who
will be subverted through fear it gets
easier and easier the more people you
cram into one space look up soviet union
look up the tribune to the blinkers
i was about to do russian
obama talking about treblinkas
because my hat the two the two got
confused you can't do it no it's really
it's hard for me to do the the voice and
then go straight into the the
kazakhstani or something over here yeah
no to me get in my own mind all week
you ain't black so you get out of cities
don't be politically indifferent
obviously is important you guys need to
take an active role
do purchase firearms that's a big one
that's a big one that's a fail that's a
fail stop when people say oh you think
you think you're gonna fight off yes yes
yes i absolutely do i do think that a
government is more well behaved i mean
look at australia as a perfect example
and there's a mandatory gun buyback look
at while we're talking about world war
ii look at what happened uh and i know
some of you will argue with switzerland
in geography but a big part of it was
that every single person had a gun it
was uh i believe mandatory for uh swiss
service yeah if i'm not mistaken i
believe that they were all trained in
the uh there were a lot of guns put it
this way there were a lot of guns in
mountainous regions uh you understand
this you understand that even the
japanese said about the united states if
there was to be a home invasion in the
united states that there would be a
farmer with a gun around every corner
and in every grassy field this is
something that is well known and at the
very least let's say you don't believe
that it's really a deterrent
it's not going to hurt
it's a good idea right if a government
wants to go in door-to-door which is
what they eventually do rounding people
up not saying that's happening here in
the united states happened in australia
right went door-to-door rounding people
up saying that you could go to a
voluntary quarantine camp and by
voluntary we mean you drive yourself or
we charge you 5 500 and you get in a cop
car
that happened there you don't just have
to think about being rounded up and
being taken to uh gas chambers people
have been rounded up for for far more
reasons than that and so some people
just want to take one extreme example
when you
i think it's a real disservice we need
to do another segment just in the
history of of stalin's russia because a
lot of people don't realize sometimes i
think he was worse than hitler
and they're both bad don't get me wrong
he killed far more people he killed far
more people hitler ever dreamed of
hitler's hitler if hat he had had his
way would not have killed nearly as many
as is that true it is 100 oh yeah no
there were probably learned something
new every day
50 to 75 million during the the time
period around world war ii yeah and uh
hitler killed i think six million jews
six million gypsies blacks professors uh
political enemies so about 12 million
people roughly right maybe a little bit
more if you counted some other stuff but
so less
no but there's other places no big
whoops in other places he killed more
people so if you add in all of that yeah
and he just did it through classism
because if it you know it wasn't
necessarily as ethnically diverse 75
million that's that's the estimates it's
some people say it's up to a hundred
i've heard it as high as 100 million
i've never heard anyone legitimately
argue lower than 50. mussolini was the
one that was like hung and spit on
though what happened to stalin well he
also killed
mussolini was like the little brother no
one respected right he wanted to be in
the club he's like he was there guys me
too yeah no not something there's some
mussolini yeah come on
i can build fashion
i can kill millions you like a pizza
oh i'm a spicy dictator
so
hey by the way just a quick question for
you if if guns are not a deterrent to a
a government uh overreaching why is it
that in history the first thing that
governments do with right before they
take over is take take your guns yeah
well it's always so funny is when you
hear people who get mad when i said of
course hitler was uh what was was left
uh because national socialist party they
go what about the national party the
socialist part also the disarming part
they go uh no he didn't disarm just the
jews well you know what i don't want to
disarm anybody it'd be like me saying
well i don't want to disarm just the
blacks i mean no look if you disarm any
subsection of the united states
that's wrong if you decide of course
it's still disarmament when you look at
what they did in nazi germany that's the
first thing they always do he was
disarming the people he was about to
kill absolutely if they say if beto says
i'm coming for your guns
do the math i know it's hard to take him
at his word because he lies a lot but we
think he's serious this time maybe this
time
well usually the reaction is a farmer of
mexican heritage tells you to leave yes
hey by the way you know who wished they
had guns in every single field and by
behind every single blade of grass right
now ukrainians yeah
it matters guys yeah they're about to be
taken over by russia and the rest of the
world is kind of diddling their thumb
saying i don't really think he's going
to do it this time i know he took that
other part of ukraine last time i just
don't think well but i believe ussr you
don't know how lucky you are something
like that
you are boy you're back back
back in the ussr yeah i don't think a
big deal i i think uh a lot of people
say this and it's so silly they go what
do you think you're going to fight off
the government uh with your guns and i'm
not i'm not encouraging of course any
type of violent incident that's not what
we're talking about but we are talking
about the reason for the second
amendment
yes here's it's a very easy answer when
people say these things too they go you
think you're gonna you think you're
gonna fight the government with nukes
and drones
100 yeah
yep look at what happens in the uk do
are they just nuking the ukraine
look at what what happened okay let's
say you believe that the united states
is the axis of evil as i know many of
you do in your social studies programs
in college all right
what happened in afghanistan
yeah twice russia and the united states
afghanistan syria he can't find an isis
think about this for a second you're
talking about people who had guns and
didn't even know how to use them
and they were able to fight off the most
powerful
economic superpower the world has ever
seen
now i wish that weren't the case but the
truth is unless you're dealing with the
country who
a government that just wants to
evaporate all of its natural resources
and human resources of course
the war that takes place before the war
is an information war a propaganda war
and getting rid of all of your enemies
and by the way who are your enemies all
it's it's different in every country
where you look at it like the soviet
union or you look at it like not you
look at places like nazi germany but
guess what the people who are your
enemies if you are a totalitarian
government always include every single
person who has a gun
outside of the cops
outside of those who will enforce the
laws stripping the citizens of their
arms and this is again what we're
talking about consistency
i am not forced to suspend my belief and
understanding of human nature to say you
should be able to own a gun and i also
understand why police officers need
firearms and not just tasers
i don't understand how you can say why
you need a gun call the cops who have
guns by the way uh black lives matter
because of police brutality again
i see human nature the same across the
world human beings are inherently flawed
they're inherently evil we're inherently
sinful and so we need those checks and
balances not only systems of government
but we need those checks and balances
among ourselves and a part of that is an
armed populace that's a more polite
populace and at the very least even if
you think that it's not if you think
that oh well more guns could lead to
more violence yeah but you know what
it's more morally reprehensible
to uh bar someone their right to defend
themselves against the violent and
corrupt than it is to me
to understand that some people will act
violently and corruptly
this is just personal opinion to me it's
far more of a tragedy to read of a woman
who was gang-raped because she was
defenseless than for example the bloods
and the crips shooting it out in south
central l.a it's different
they're both bad
one is worse especially when you're
talking about that being the result of
any kind of government mandate which
we've seen across all totalitarian
regimes so i'll leave you with this what
else can we do i want to read this uh
quote actually from uh someone who i
believe all the statues have been
removed i think they're all going thank
god uh there's this little thing the
declaration of independence there was a
little the guy named thomas jefferson
remember that name i think he's going to
catch on
uh he wrote whenever any form of
government becomes destructive of these
ends life liberty and the pursuit of
happiness we've heard that before it is
the right of the people to alter or
abolish it and to institute new
government contrast that with what we
just talked about barack obama former
vice president joe biden
and putin and what the new york times
had written is government is here to
help hey no sometimes people mistrust
their government we need to make sure
that everyone trusts their institutions
here's the beauty of our institutions
here in the united states and i know
this one's going to be a little bit of a
doozy okay it's a head scratcher
our institutions were created
specifically to sow continual distrust
in our institutions so that you
consistently reform them and hold them
accountable
not that you ingrain them deeper you
know like a lizzo uh like a lizzo grave
all right we are going to go to youtube
and bring in austin to talk about how
racist uh koreans and chinese people can
be so we can't talk about this on
youtube he's kareem it's okay piss off
bye